one of the dread four horsemen of the
apocalypse is pestilence the plagues
that have scourge mankind since earliest
times of these none has claimed more
lives than the white plague tuberculosis
some of the greatest names in medicine
have waged the war against TB sans
epocrates first defined its symptoms 500
years before the time of Christ but it
was a little more than a hundred years
ago that the chance observation of
children listening to the magnified
sounds of tapping on a hollow log gave
the neck a young French doctor the
inspiration for the stethoscope later in
the 19th century velleman proved that TB
was a contagious disease then Louie
fester discovered that germs were the
cause of contagious disease the German
scientist Koch was the first to find the
TB germ the tubercle bacillus but not
until Renkin discovered x-ray could the
actual destruction caused by the germ be
seen inside the living body modern
sanatorium treatment in this country
began in the Adirondacks when Trudeau
found that rest fresh air and good food
helped him to recover from the
supposedly incurable TV 1900 and with
the new century came a new idea to fight
TV with knowledge to teach people about
TB so that it can be found early when
chances for recovery are best with this
in mind a group of scientists physicians
and other public spirited citizens
founded what is now the national
tuberculosis Association from these
beginnings came the local TB association
in your community formed by your
neighbors of the interest of better
public health here's how it works the
people elect a board of directors
representing a cross-section of the
community businessmen in housewives
churchmen doctors educators newspaper
man
industrialists and legislators the board
employs an executive secretary together
they plan a program for tuberculosis
control the secretary needs a staff of
trained technical workers to mobilize
the army of volunteers so necessary for
community action against TB a program
begins with fact-finding the Secretary
must know how many deaths were caused by
TB during the past year are there enough
doctors nurses social workers sanatorium
beds clinics and hospitals are there
special groups in the community with a
higher incidence of TB for his
information the secretary consults
agencies like these from them he can
fill in his picture of the community
learn its weak points know how to build
the most effective program of primary
importance to such a program is health
education carefully planned with the
help of other community organizations
for education must be more than merely
telling a story it must influence
behavior form habits of thought and
action additional persons must be
reached through those already educated
finally it must create a demand for more
education for which leadership has been
developed thus the Association plans its
educational program for the use of such
groups as teachers and school
administrators speakers churchmen and
those being trained for professional
careers doctors nurses and social
workers the Association can reach all
groups because its board of directors is
drawn from all aspects of community life
largely an educational job is the phase
of the association's work known as
case-finding control of TB depends on
finding the people who have it before
there are symptoms before the victims
them
cells are aware of it unknown cases are
often found by the family physician in
the course of physical examinations and
among young people by tuberculin testing
in the schools if people are made aware
of the value of periodic chest x-ray the
t be discovered will usually be in the
early stage if however TB has not looked
for until the patient displays symptoms
of the disease the case is found or apt
to be in the far advanced state when
cure is uncertain and costly the
association may be called upon to
furnish x-ray equipment x-ray film or
technical and clerical services until
such time as the Health Department can
take over the responsibility since TB
control depends on finding unknown and
unsuspected cases a program to wipe out
the disease must strive to x-ray every
adult in the community to do this the
health department and the tuberculosis
Association organize local committees
made up of public spirited volunteers
with their help and with the impetus
given the drive by industry church
school and welfare groups complete
coverage of the community is assured
those individuals whose x-ray indicates
t be re-examined by the private
physician and the Health Department the
local Association may help by supplying
public health nursing social service or
other professional aids as a
demonstration to the community to show
for example the need for adequate
following up of the case follow-up work
includes the medical examination and
x-ray of contacts the family and close
associates of the person found to have
TB when the person with TB is receiving
treatment the association works with a
sanatorium staff to give him and his
family the facts they need to know about
TB the patient must be prepared for
instance for a long period of bed
treatment perhaps training for a new job
will be necessary for early in his
sanatorium stay the association and
other agencies are beginning to plan for
his eventual convalescence and
reemployment once discharged from the
sanatorium he can look to his family
physician as well as his TV association
and Health Department for advice on his
job is recreation and the facilities
available for physical checkup if the
facilities for helping discharge
patients and their families do not exist
the association must try to influence
the proper agencies to appropriate funds
to cover the needs among the greatest
influencing factors open to the TB
association are the channels of public
information the press from the large
dailies to the handwritten school
newspapers radio and television a
year-round public information campaign
invaluable as an aid to an educational
program also serves to tell you how your
money is being spent what is being done
for the public helping your community
the entire program of the tuberculosis
Association is financed by the sale of
Christmas seals primarily through the
mail or by volunteers selling TB seals
and hell
bonds of the money collected in the
community 95% remains in the community
and state where it was raised thus the
people who contributed can see the
visible results of service within their
community the remaining five percent
goes to the National Association which
like the State Association exists as a
service organization for the local
channeling information producing
materials and giving consultation these
three the national state and local
associations work together to further TB
control on their respective levels in
some instances they can extend their
work to other health needs they also
work together in the large program of
research from which it is hoped will
eventually come the cure for the disease
meanwhile tuberculosis once the cause of
more deaths than any other single
disease is being defeated in the United
States with the weapons now available
the goal of your tuberculosis
Association is to stamp out t be forever
in your community you can help